I'm not drunk I am not drunk I am not
drunk I'm not drunk I'm not drunk I'm
not drunk I'm not drunk
I don't drink
you know what I'm saying because I don't
like the when the breasts think
[Music]
oh yeah it tastes like hydration hi
everyone I'm I'm Tara I go by Dr Tara
okay Doctor go crazy go crazy my name's
Elvis Portillo I'm from Las Vegas from
Las Vegas
my name for you for you I'm the mall
right there
I'm not Dr Christine I'm
stain
I'm Steve hi sir hi um pretty much
everywhere Africa France you name it
Shay hi everyone I'm from Germany I
lived in London last but reasons as to
why I'm not the most because my accent's
weird that's why I'm not drunk I promise
I'm from here I'm from L.A I'm an actor
and I'm a model and a dancer and yeah I
suck at drinking but my name is Gabe I
I've never traveled because the budget
is it the budget is not there
um yeah super sober
this guy sounds like he's faced you're
super sober that's exactly what a drunk
person would say I'm like are you drunk
I don't know I don't know okay let
everybody wink okay
okay
[Music]
[Laughter]
just because you're from Vegas
hey good humans we're taking a quick
break here to thank liquid IV for
sponsoring this episode and for giving
you all a chance to win one year of free
liquid IV hydration multipliers more on
that in a second
liquid I've used hydration multiplier is
a great tasting electrolyte drink mix
that's perfect for staying hydrated it
comes in delicious flavors like lemon
lime concord grape strawberry lemonade
and several more
not only do they taste amazing hydration
multiplier also offers two times faster
hydration than water alone featuring
three times the electrolytes of a
traditional sports drinks
we're constantly on the go at Jubilee
especially when it comes to making these
videos and hydration multiplier has the
convenient on-the-go packaging that
makes it easier than ever to hydrate
throughout the day
check out the link in the description to
learn how to enter liquid IV sweepstakes
for a chance to win one year of free
liquid IV hydration multipliers now
let's get back to the episode
[Music]
[Applause]
it's like getting boot off stage you
just don't know what to expect you just
get the oh I even said I'm not drunk I'm
not even I'm no even close to drunk it's
just like I'm high all low guys I
actually have an idea everybody show one
dance move to see if they they're a
little limping or something you know
okay the same thing so I'll go first
oh damn like you're good
at a party when you were like drinking
you were like in the mood and you're
like ready to like bust moves and I was
thinking that might be a giveaway little
kick
all right all right wait what was the
case
[Applause]
[Music]
Elvis's dance move it would not have
been my go-to I don't really know how to
dance well I don't want people to think
I'm drunk just because I can't like Bust
A Move what's your relationship with
your mother like oh geez yeah
you right
if you're asking about mommy issues it
means you want everyone to talk except
yourself
um I don't know traumatic I'm Mexican so
it's difficult
okay mine's amazing we're best friends
nice oh we've had a rocky road but I
think we're kind of like working our way
back together now me and my mom were
kind of separated for a while or we just
recently kind of reconnected nice yeah I
feel like we're such the same person
that we click sometimes but it's a work
in progress gotcha
how about you uh pretty good yeah who
knows relationships with mothers go ups
and downs but love it to this yeah yeah
I feel like drunk people like to over
share so that was like a question
okay should we try Jubilee backwards
oh English is not your first language
[Music]
foreign
looking at her eyes they kind of seemed
like they were like moving everywhere
they were just like nervous
he just seemed like he was trying to
figure out how to be sober like he was
thinking a lot we counted all the votes
and we have a tie breaker between chai
and Isabelle
interesting I'm gonna let everyone
choose a tie breaker you want them to do
oh what balance okay balance one leg oh
okay that's about like hop on one leg
like 10 times go
okay they're too good yeah there's like
the Peter Piper picked yeah typical
Peppers exactly yeah I'll say it slowly
and then you all say it fast Peter Piper
picked a patch of pickled peppers Peter
Piper picked a peck of pickled pickles
pickles
Peter picked up a bunch of them
Peter picked some peppers
that's what I thought they said she
couldn't say the the peck I'm drunk I
don't know Pig Peppa Pig Peppa pigging
like she couldn't say it so I'm like you
drunk Isabel
[Laughter]
[Music]
Isabel
sorry baby
love your outfit
I already knew they was going to call me
out these people they around people like
me a lot you know what I'm saying with
some spice with some flavor so they're
gonna think I have something going on
but I'm just hard all the time
if you think the mall is still in the
box and you'd like to continue playing
the game please raise your hand I
actually feel like we've gone
I think just one more round just have a
suspicion yeah one more round okay yep
we're gonna have each of you take a shot
it's going to be a shot of water for
everyone except for the mole
[Music]
I suspected Tara the way her eyes
started glaring how smooth she just took
it and kind of smiled back at us and
just walked away smiling
foreign
[Music]
he said Bottoms Up and I think that that
made me a little bit suspicious because
everyone else was trying really hard to
keep a straight face
let's get it
[Music]
oh yeah
he took a while to like swallow
maybe a cover up like the burning
sensation of the drink
[Music]
one of you guys was way too good at that
if that's your Vodka face whoever it is
do we need to talk
do you have a problem okay I have a
quick question did you drive here yes
but you drove here all the way from Las
Vegas all the way from today today
interesting and you're planning on going
back there at the hotel right next door
I'm going back tonight how long is the
drive it's about four hours from here in
Los Angeles
did you drive here yes did you I did did
you hmm
of course I don't know I'm like trying
to see the eyes like when I'm drunk my
eye is like glossy as well I started
just my words for some reason you're
really quiet I'm just kind of shy I can
talk what made you want to go on a
jubilee show if you're kind of shy good
good question that's a good question I
mean I just graduated college I went to
USC and I feel like I thank you I feel
like I was a commuter student and I
didn't really get to have a lot of fun
so when there was an opening for this I
was like let me just try and do it and
okay really excited so then you got lit
before you come here or no I drove here
so I couldn't but okay I might after
interesting
[Music]
oh I drove from Vegas four hours after
this I'm gonna drive four hours back to
Vegas that's a lie you're drunk and
you're gonna go back to the hotel next
door
I definitely want to get rid of her she
started kind of going after me so I had
to kind of get defensive and start going
out to Earth
Elvis damn
oh man it hit me right here in the soul
like it hurt if you think the mole is
still in the box and you'd like to
continue playing the game please raise
your hand
I don't know
I kind of I think we got them please
raise your hand
so the game is over okay
so the lights
turn green that means you have voted
them all out and you all win if the
light turns red that means the mole is
still in the box and you lose
three
two
one
[Music]
it's you I knew it I knew it it's you
she really voted her every time oh my
God
on the count of three the mole will step
forward and reveal themselves three
two one
she was way too quiet
she was the quietest person in the room
when you that drunk you don't speak
I felt so much joy that the people that
took me out didn't get the money
that's what y'all
took five shots of vodka and then right
before we filmed I took another two
shots of vodka how drunk are you is it
how drunk are you on a scale of one to
ten I'm probably like a seven so
[Laughter]
oh my God being drunk really helped with
my fear of being shy on camera it was
able to kind of help me tune into a more
bubbly outgoing side of myself the only
time I did lie during the game was about
getting here my boyfriend's been waiting
for me so I did in fact not drive here
if you like this episode and want to see
more then make sure to subscribe to our
Channel
[Laughter]
[Applause]
thank you